So, let's see if we know how to
add some prefetch instructions.
Suppose we have a program like this
where i goes from 0 to 1000 and
j goes from 0 to 1000 and
in every iteration of this inner
loop we add to the ith element of
the a array the element of the b matrix.
So what is really happening here, is
that in the first iteration of the outer
loop, we will compute a[0],
then a[1], and so on, and we do that
by basically adding up all the
appropriate elements from the b array.
Let's say that the elements of the a and
b arrays are both
floating point numbers,
that they're each 8 bytes in size.
Let's say that the cache size is 16kB,
fully associative, with LRU replacement.
Let's say that a single
iteration of this inner loop
takes 10 cycles if there are no misses,
and that the miss penalty
is 200 cycles, because the memory
latency is 200 cycles.
The question for you is, if we insert
a prefetch instruction here so
that we can prefetch one of
the next a elements, what should
be the distance here or check this,
if we simply should not be doing this.
Here, for
prefetching elements of B in this loop,
what is the distance at which
we should be prefetching?
Or should we just not be doing this?